we got breaking news uh this from the
post-millennial Twitter has disbanded
its Infamous trust and Safety Council as
Twitter moves into a new phase we are
re-evaluating how best to bring external
insights into our product and policy
development work as a part of this
process we have decided that the trust
and Safety Council is not the best
structure to do this
there you go let's do it to be fair it
wasn't very trustworthy and it didn't
keep a lot of people safe yeah double
speak it didn't do any of that it just
banned political speech that's exactly
what it did also it's very curious to
see a lot of these members of of the the
trust and Safety Council kind of
publicly resign after Elon Musk
specifically said that he's going to be
going after child exploitation and adult
content on their website a little
curious about how that happened do you
think that they were asked to keep it on
as like Honeypot stuff that crosses that
there is some speculation but it's all
speculation but the daily wire also
reported that there was uh allegedly 10
million views of child adult content
material that was watched on the old
Twitter 10 million views that's a lot of
views but what this is confusing this is
the daily wires there's a big difference
between a nine-year-old that's you know
some horrible thing is happening in a 17
year old there's a big difference in
some states 16 is the age of consent
yeah but because because of the fact
that we because of the fact that you
can't make a law that is arbitrary you
have to have a dividing you know you
have to have some point where it says
okay this is where we make the decision
uh you you can't have laws that are
arbitrary like that so you have to say
some place an 18 is as good a place of
any and I think that the argument for
the argument should only be going for
older just because of the way that the
brain develops you know I think that
it's I would I would people that say oh
we should uh we should make sure that
the age to drink and and buy a gun and
to vote and all that stuff is is you
know the same I don't see why they think
it should be made younger that just
doesn't make any sense to me at all you
know well they've been trying to get
everything they want they want the
voting age to be 16. Democrats because
low information voters is how they win
then you get 16 year olds you get
Universal mail-in ballots and then there
you go simple as that well they
eliminated the trust and Safety Council
they say our work is to make Twitter a
safe informative Place uh will be moving
faster and more aggressively than ever
before and we will continue oh say we
will be moving faster and we will
continue to welcome your ideas going
forward about how to achieve this goal
we'll also continue to explore
opportunities to provide focused and
timely input into our work whether
through bilateral or small group
meetings I don't think that there's a
whole lot of uh argument about the fact
that Twitter is far more responsive now
to most people's inquiries than they
ever were before Elon Musk yeah you know
it's not on the platform it's not like
you could tweet at Jack and expect Jack
to do anything or you could tweet at uh
you know parag and expect Prague to do
anything they would just ignore you he's
responding and even explaining a lot of
his unpopular actions like like not
allowing Alex Jones on the platform he
at least gave an explanation we didn't
like it it wasn't a good explanation but
would we get that ever with Google no
with YouTube
yeah I love when the CEO is involved but
uh at the same time I'm concerned about
centralized systems because we were
saying earlier it's cool that Tesla and
SpaceX and Twitter are coming together
to form this Uber mind of communications
and travel but if the FBI hacks into it
if some foreign government hacks into it
if someone buys the companies away from
Elon and then wants to just own Humanity
so we gotta decentralize these systems
these software codes get it out of any
individual's hands as fast as possible
because I do not like one guy making the
decision of who I got to stay and who
has to go I gotta push back on that
because
Elon Musk as the one guy
that owns Tesla and starlink and and
Twitter and stuff that's fine because
the option is government which is run by
bureaucracies and is not responsive and
and all the problems that we had with
with Twitter you get from government
because there's nameless faceless
bureaucrats that are that that that
literally comprise the entrenched
bureaucracy or the Deep State you you
either get so Sargon avocad Carl
Benjamin has been talking about this
idea which I forget the the the way that
he articulates it but it's essentially
where one guy is in the right place at
the right time and is the right person
to do something and
it's it's kind of like a convergence of
this the conditions and the person and
without the person it doesn't happen and
Elon Musk is kind of the person that has
found himself in the position to do the
things that he's doing it's not just
that
um it's not like if it wasn't for the
fact that it's Elon Musk doing it it
wouldn't happen it's not like it's it's
replaceable it's not like anyone could
be there doing it
um so the the idea of breaking it up and
having other people handle it if you
break it up and have other people
handling it there's no guarantee that it
gets done because there's not one person
with the vision and the drive to push to
make this thing happen and sometimes it
comes down to one individual pushing
with the drive and everyone coalescing
around him or people coalescing around
that idea but it's that one person
pushing that really kind of becomes the
cattle and we could argue that uh
Twitter is just acting as an arm of the
government with the FBI getting getting
involved and manipulating the public
perception on things with uh cyber
command operations psyops Etc it's just
essentially a function of government
I mean I'm sympathetic to to the the
intent behind what you're saying which
is you want to make sure that an
individual doesn't become corrupt and
derail uh progress towards a certain
goal but I think that having
the option between the right person
pushing for an idea or for a result
versus a bureaucracy trying to come up
with a result I feel like the right
person is the better option not to say
that every individual is the right
person just because you have a person in
a position that's you know has Authority
doesn't mean that that person's gonna
get it done because Charisma and the
ability to work with people and so many
other things go into it that's why it
has to be the right person but I think
that the right person is better than a
bureaucracy the two people I think of in
this example would be Julius Caesar and
George Washington both of them
ultimately ultimate military power
behind one man Washington it was a group
of thinkers that said hey George you're
going to take this for now yeah George
was able to let it go yeah and we need
people like that I think because Caesar
was not I think that that's that's I
think you're right I think that that is
a A very wise take because it is it does
the matter the person and you're right
because Washington is the guy that said
I have to get I want to give this power
back and I think you're right yeah yeah
it could have either been stolen from
him he held on to it someone could have
assassinated him and become the next
king or um you know any God number of
god-awful things could happen if he
tried to hold on to the power I
understand what you're saying that one
guy can move quickly you can get a lot
done authoritarian regimes including
corporations move quickly because
there's one guy making the decision a
girl but the danger of that for the
social Public Square ooh I don't like I
don't see that wait until you Elon
though because someone tweeted at him
and said hey I hope SpaceX and Tesla are
running well with how much time you
spend on Twitter he's like actually the
teams are in place are really good at
what they do so he's already kind of
passing the torch down he kind of just
oversees and puts his name on the
companies yeah plus he's got to post
spicy memes way more important than
Rockets all right so I mean Morocco you
know so that's got to milk the law cows
the meme of the digging up Twitter
secrets in the grave you saw that you
posted that no that was pretty good look
every segment we've had so far has been
about Elon he's just the main character
at this point I guess isn't he uh
unfortunately he's the guy that's
especially considering it's the holidays
he's the guy that's driving the national
conversation and thankfully things have
kind of chilled out in the Ukrainian war
and I say thankfully because that means
fewer people are dying every day when
there's less fighting and that to me is
good
um you know and so I guess that Elon
Musk is the thing to talk about it
didn't chill out it just kind of
literally stopped because of the winter
yeah some of the fighting but they're
still using drone Fair which is
absolutely crazy I just gotta give a
shout out to the latest episode of Rick
and Morty I don't know I don't know if
you guys watch it but there's the
president's in it and he makes a joke
where something happens and he goes well
we'll just blame it on the Saudis they
do this kind of thing they've done this
kind of thing they did do this thing it
was just so well done I was like that's
exactly exactly what happens they did
they did do this thing I wouldn't mind
seeing a meme of Elon in a graveyard
cross-legged meditating and all the
spirits of the ghosts are coming out of
the graves of all this Twitter you heard
in the internet well I think it's hard
to say he is the new Mass formation
psychosis Target he's the one that the
corporate media is is
centralizing their attacks against
they're they're attacking them more than
they are actually covering the
corruption that was at Twitter that was
at the FBI which is very Talent they're
trying to make yellow some kind of
victim here they're trying to make Dr
fauci some kind of victim here these are
not actual victims here yoel Roth
literally tweeted about how high school
teachers calling for them to have
meaningful consent with their teachers
like
how do you even ask if they could the
answer just no yes so instead of asking
you say they can't why wouldn't you be
even asking that specific question I I
agree but you see hold on you see the
game is playing a regular person doesn't
ask they just say a child can't consent
to be with their teacher yeah he goes
but can they no are the like literally
the only reason that I'm that I'm that I
say that is so that way like tomorrow or
in a couple days when someone's like oh
blah blah blah like I can say no like I
said
you know I said the actual thing right
and then I can be like you know that's
what why the hell does he say it that's
an example of doing what's right versus
doing what you want yeah like sometimes
you just gotta acknowledge the
objectivity of these Psychopaths yeah or
acknowledge the fact that he's getting
you know that he's he might be playing
word games or whatever and you know it
might be just the way that he's
articulating stuff thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time